hello and welcome to this video playing
to balk yeah let's do something else I
had struggled in a caracal against
recently so i'm going for something else
I have something in mind here this line
that's not such a bad line and very
suitable as a secondary weapon not sure
that you should play it like every game
but now and then it doesn't hurt to
record the Siuslaw system okay he's
trying to play Bishop a 6cm probably
successfully this move okay so there
will be something happening on this
e-file yeah I guess so what's going on
here
I wonder if I should just go before
trying to play five you cannot win a
pony I think should be able to Travis
Queen yep my DSE five he currently
doesn't have anything in the center so
you five is a bit annoying these
happiness is weekend so yes problems
with them moving the night
hmm not so easier black now to play a
move of course queen bee six was played
in a split second not sure what you
should do him hard to not lose the
material
yeah he goes for my piece and so II five
is the natural response so so I'm able
to win e7 now or let's be thorough here
I can also take here first right this is
probably more precise again when II 76
probably Knight c3 I guess I'll take
with the rook yeah I TM I will be able
to take each 7 and d6 no d6 I cannot
take with the think for just a moment
here so if i take it suddenly with the
bishop rookie aid should be six you can
go clean your sex film this isn't that
clear and if i take these tix just with
the pawn maybe it's not bad Queen takes
out taking seven
yeah in TN I was thinking Queenie 7 this
night doesn't have that many good
squares probably I still at something
bad I am that doesn't feel like a
refutation not good I should just take
it I think that just take it seven keep
it simple yeah this is nothing here
really I mean I'm strategically better
but I'm not winning and I should should
be winning somehow okay
night against bishop es should be a good
material distribution with this
weaknesses him and fortunately rookie
force it's very disturbing
[Music]
yeah not so good let's play some simple
moves and then see what happens maybe
before is an option a4 was helpful
anyway for me I think
Ruby aid will be one I will get this
back what do you see up to I don't
understand it some tactic here that I
don't understand so if i take this
mmm does he get active on the second
maybe yes
so let's see here it's not easy to
coordinate a three years time morning
yeah that doesn't help really now I
didn't judge that correctly I was
thinking I might have some winning
chances here but this is this is
certainly not the case
[Music]
okay no d620 the bishop is very strong
now always covering Wow
[Music]
keep a gentler method least I can play
many balls in this rogue ending and I'm
blend with this no it doesn't it doesn't
try to use this check check check check
nice port this ending no check doing
this check check check check stalemate
Jesus ah Christ no the only way they
absolutely only aim oh my god
yeah it's just a mysterious game and you
don't really understand what's what goes
on in yeah this is equal ish and yeah I
misjudged that I thought I might have
some some some ways to do it but it just
he's just far too active so a draw would
be okay and then you just play look T to
for no reason I mean I just take it
doesn't make any sense yeah I TM okay
objectively best is probably rook see
tool but playing against the spawn is
very disturbing with no child so I
thought I can just play walk in here yet
g4 of course i blundered dad he could
have played g4 wine this position I
don't know why he didn't King be one
okay maybe yeah check now the NIJ all
those chains and it was an easy win but
yeah you can stalemate with two seconds
on the clock okay the only thing doubts
I'm just pretty awful in the opening
anyway I should just take his hand
probably yeah that was just a stupid
idea some are even it escaped me that he
can just take with the pawn I mean this
was the idea all along why can't I take
this I thought this would work oopsie a
it okay yeah I didn't see that one I
just thought back here that I don't have
a good move that was my issue here I
thought 26 also i always have this move
I didn't see this idea I mean this was
the original intention of course to just
take this and resins but I thought you
can take because of my unprotected Queen
this is winning of course
oh wow yeah so I mean I had to do many
things they're not to win thanks for
watching